okay sorry ladybug okay so a halloween
costume ceo
put me in a pop group okay later and you
were in lady baby and how long did that
go
well uh i was in lady baby so my first
ever song nippon manju blew up on the
internets
and it got very very popular and so now
we were the hottest group
and so when this was formed you had you
didn't have any say in who the two idols
were literally we're putting with two
people
be friends i was told you're doing the
script yeah that's right um
so that happened uh i was in lady baby
for like a year and a half or something
so i did like four singles with them
and then some other kind of b-side touch
songs as well um
due to a series of events i won't go
into uh i was
unceremoniously relieved of my position
right um and now they don't exist
anymore was it because you're uh
at the danny's been a little too
bitter
every time you know what yeah
it turns out when you choose a heavy
metal singer you want him to be as
quiet
so then yeah so then you did the lady
baby stuff and then you kind of did a
whole other bunch of other stuff
my time in that group ended um they went
on without me but now they're
done anyway yeah yeah that whole thing
has come to an end um
i went and uh i did some other stuff uh
but
now you have a new group finally got a
new group
right so everyone loved
ladybaby when i was there right so me
and the two cute little japanese girls
everyone loved it i'm like let's do that
for a again of reasons we couldn't for
five years
right basically sum it up japanese
showbiz politics right
basically we did some other stuff i was
have been happy with the other stuff
i've done
um but now in a position where we can do
it again
so i'm like sweet as let's do it again
so basically what we've done is we've
constructed
as many of the parts that came together
to make nippon manju as we could
we've reconstructed those right and
we're doing the same thing again
and it's i'm very excited because for
five years
i've been every day been told why'd you
leave ladybug i wanted you to keep doing
it yeah
every day for five years yeah so finally
i can do this formation again because
clearly it's
it's what i want to do it's what the
whole world wants to see so
brace yourselves ladies and gentlemen
ladybeard2021
coming at you with brand new group i'm
allowed to release brand new group's
name correct
ladies gentlemen baby beard coming at
you
baby beard that makes
more sense than lady baby it does it
does like
like as a name right thought
at that naming meeting i was like i
don't want baby
why not baby beer yeah you're gonna take
that approach yeah no no
no no no no no no lady baby lady baby
let's ignore the one person in the room
who speaks english his idea of a good
english name
so baby beard is unlike donkey kong i'm
so excited
uh have you done stuff with them yet
this whole thing was ready to get up and
get running at the beginning of 2020.
we all know what happened today we all
know what happened to that yeah so now
we're in this
um unique position where we have a new
group to release
and we're not really capable of doing
all the things you normally do to
release a group
right you're kind of stuck
so what you need to do is you need to
head down
to the baby beard tik tok there you're
gonna see
all the latest from baby beard coming at
you
full of updates and all the things we're
gonna be doing as soon as we're allowed
to do normal things like
be on a stage i love how like this is
the first
guest that we've had that's just like
[ __ ] the end of the show no
i'm promoting my [ __ ] now hi hi
hi you're a true showman
[Music]
hey go to social media
baby
[Laughter]
the instant ham do we have another one
that i'm forgetting about
we'll put all the links in the
description in the description
smash the like button that's what the
young people say nowadays
but they don't say it in the middle of
the episode
at the end
this podcast is just starting
every five minutes we're walking them
back every toilet break welcome back
anyway i have a new group called baby
beard me the two adorable japanese girls
it's gonna be fantastic
if you loved nippon manju you will love
this go watch it please
oh
it's a great table actually i'm just
glad you're sticking with something
familiar for once not going to like
[ __ ] astrophysics or something yeah
right
i don't know much